hi guys in the recent videos I've told
you what not to eat in this video we're
going to talk about what you can eat
specifically pleasure Foods okay on the
ketogenic diet um here's the thing you
know you might in your mind think that
it's very restrictive but there are so
many recipes and every single recipe
that I'm going to tell you about I
actually put a link down below you can
actually get the recipe all right so
first we have bread there's a certain
type of bread that you can make on this
eating plan and it is amazing pancakes
with almond FL uh you have pizza with
cauliflower crust I mean a lot of you
have already made that it's delicious
waffles not just waffles but maple syrup
okay we show you how to make the syrup
and the waffles unbelievable bread
sticks that actually taste like bread
sticks peacon pie do you like peacon pie
this thing you're going to really love
this no sugar it's low carb shortbread
cookie one of my favorite cookies I mean
this you cannot tell the difference
between this cookie in an actual
shortbread cookie ice cream yes ice
cream spice nut mix unbelievable whipped
cream chocolate keto fat
bombs those are things that you can take
at the end of the meal that like a
dessert peanut butter cups unbelievable
cheddar biscuits chocolate chip cookies
do you like those you'll love this
recipe chocolate
mousse candied
peans and chocolate seeds these are just
a few that you can make now I have a
little sample here's an example look it
we got we got candied peans we got the
short bed cookie and we got the ice
cream now tell me this wouldn't be a
substitute for any type of other dessert
that you would
consume amazing
amazing this ice cream is actually my
own ice cream that we're working on I've
been working on this for a year now and
a lot of you have been asking when is it
going to be
done soon I want it perfect so we keep
going back and forth back and forth
until it's just the texture is
absolutely perfect because we have to
make this with less than one gram of
sugar with higher amounts of fat we
finally made it with coconut oil yeah
and it fluffs up just like ice cream so
go ahead and click the recipe that you
want to make down below and don't don't
deprive
yourself so press the Subscribe button
and this is misspelled so I can't spell
so I'm going to have to add that in here
okay take two press the Subscribe button
and I I can't even say this press the
Subscribe button and I will keep you
updated on the future events